[Music]
by now we are quite familiar with the
shape ellipse can you tell me what an
ellipse is right if we have two fixed
points then an ellipse is the set of
points such that the sum of the
distances from these two fixed points is
constant these two fixed points are
called the full size of the ellipse we
can also draw two axis of symmetry for
an ellipse this is called the major axis
and this one is the minor axis and this
point equidistant from the four side is
called the center of the ellipse take a
moment and have a look at this ellipse
in this video let's find out the
equation of an ellipse we know that for
this we will first have to draw the
coordinate axis that is the x axis and
the y axis what will be the simplest way
to draw the coordinate axes here right
we can take the center of the ellipse as
the origin the x axis along the major
axis and the y axis along the minor axis
actually turns out that the equation of
an ellipse is simplest when the center
of the ellipse is at the origin and the
force I are on the x axis or the y axis
this is one of the possible orientations
of the ellipse satisfying these
conditions here the force I are on the x
axis another possible orientation is
when the force I are on the y axis and
the center at the origin so here
the major axis is along the y axis and
the Minor axis along the x axis will
there be any more possible orientations
of an ellipse satisfying these
conditions no these two are the only two
possible orientations satisfying these
conditions so we will only consider
these two orientations let's first find
the equation of an ellipse for this
orientation with the force I on the x
axis tell me aunt
now what do we know about an ellipse yes
we know that for any point on the
ellipse its sum of distances from the
force is constant do you know what will
be the value of this constant it turns
out that this constant will be equal to
the length of the major axis how let's
see let the length of the semi-major
axis be a and also that the distance
between the center and the focus of the
ellipse be C now consider this point Q
at one end of the major axis what will
be its sum of distances from the four
side it will be the sum of this distance
Q F 1 which will be C plus a and this
distance Q F 2 which will be equal to a
minus C so we get this we can see that
the sum is equal to 2 times a and we
know that for any point on the ellipse
its sum of distances from the fossae
will be this constant 2a and 2a is the
length of the major axis of the ellipse
so we see that for all the points on the
ellipse the constant sum of distances
from the fossae is equal to 2a which is
the length of the major axis we
discovered one more thing about the
ellipse in the previous video there is a
relationship between the semi-major axis
the semi-minor axis and the distance
from the center of the ellipse to the
focus of the ellipse now if we take the
length of the semi minor axis as B then
this is the relationship we saw earlier
so these are the two major things we
know about an ellipse let's use them to
find its equation let's take a point
beyond the ellipse with coordinates x
and y we know what sum of distances from
the four side will be equal to 2a so we
will get this now since C is the
distance between the center and each of
the two four side their coordinates will
be C comma 0 and negative C comma 0 so
we know the coordinates of these three
points therefore we can use the distance
formula to find these distances the
distance between P and F 1 will be this
and the distance between P and F 2 will
be this so we get this equation if we
simplify it we will get the equation of
the ellipse so let's quickly look at
some of the important steps in
simplifying this equation first we
transpose this term to the right-hand
side like this
now we square the terms on both sides
which will give us this then we further
simplify we will get this relatively
simple equation now we will again have
to square both sides and simplify doing
it we will get this now notice this term
a squared minus C squared we can use
this relationship to simplify it if we
square both sides of this relation we
will get this and transposing 2 terms we
get B squared is equal to a squared
minus C squared so we can substitute
this here which will give us this
equation here a is the length of the
major axis and B is the length of the
minor axis so we found out that if B is
any point on the ellipse then it's
coordinates will satisfy this equation
can we conclude from this that this is
the equation of the ellipse no right we
know that we will also have to check
whether the converse of this follows
that is any point satisfying this
equation will always lie on the ellipse
we will check this in the next lesson
we will see that this is the equation of
the ellipse to stay updated and to keep
learning such interesting things do
subscribe to our Channel
[Music]